welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and one division has
woken up the nerds from the dead like
the confused synthesizoids we are and
with the arrival of new content we have
a fun announcement for you guys
something that we have been trying to do
for a while now but we just haven't had
regular releases to do it with but now
that we do
i'm happy to announce new rockstars will
now be doing live
episodes for you guys all to connect
with us in real time i want to say that
i'm terrified but hey
i'm a live performer i do these videos
mostly in one talk
take crap can we do that again no not
anymore oh dear god here's the deal new
rockstars has partnered with stereo to
create a whole lineup of brand new
weekly live podcasts
stereo is a free live podcast social
platform that enables people to have
conversations in real time it's like a
fun mix of podcasts live streaming and
old school radio call-in shows
first up this coming wednesday january
27th is going to be
a topical news reaction show with me
and phil molina given our honest
reactions to the latest nerdy headlines
of the week that we can't fit in other
videos
it's gonna be raw we're gonna take
questions from listeners philip will
probably also jokingly try to fight me
is it a joke you're gonna have to tune
in to find out and then starting friday
january 29th we're going to
live broadcast our inside marvel one
division after show
with myself and co-host jessica clement
you're gonna be able to hear
our piping hot takes on the latest
episode hours before
it hits the youtube channel and we're
going to add a segment where we take
audio questions and reactions and
theories from the stereo users
you guys that we're gonna play on the
show and then on monday february 1st
we're gonna launch a show i had been
dying to see
in which our editors who are the ones
truly bringing so much of the humor and
joy to these videos they're gonna do
something that i am too afraid to do in
our youtube videos read the comments
it's gonna start our editors john and
josh they're gonna run through their
favorite youtube comments of the week on
all of the week's videos give you a peek
behind the curtain at new rockstars
explain why some things may be wrong in
videos why sometimes there's a weird
beam of light on my arm
or how everyone else behind the scenes
at new rockstars was screaming at me not
to do a stupid theory that's probably
not gonna be right you guys are gonna
wanna join us for these fun shows the
editors read the comic show and the show
with me and philip are only gonna be on
stereo
inside marvel will still be on our
youtube channel but there's gonna be
this special extended version that's
only on stereo
so you gotta download the free stereo
app using
our url in the description and once
you're there follow the at new rockstars
account so that you can connect with us
whenever we are live this is going to be
an exciting new venture for our channel
i am so excited to go on it with you
guys and i'll see you on stereo